she's the house to go right - bird bath
and welcome back to my latest addiction
tampon ah
Mamma Mia I have the drakes old it was
super easy to get like it took me like
three shots to get it whoa whoa what is
that look at that
BAM try blocking I don't need to do that
ever again
merchants I had sure I'm gone Sammy all
right
are you serious oh yeah serious oh how
the hell I'm gonna kill what is the plan
here going through an eye I guess oh
come on I'm alive I'm alive I'm alive
can you go upstairs can he go up says
that it's the question what am I do
without pee bad doggies oh god I felt
that Oh God all seven in the ass oh
that's a pretty nice damage there pills
now you're dead though too bad
gosh don't hit me one second now I'm a
busy this balconies the only thing I
have oh god you're so scary this balcony
is my best friend in the entire universe
I don't have any friends at a dire
divided balcony I talk to it what a save
okay let's do a jump attack Yolo Oh
let's do another jump attack on that
[ __ ] nice jump attack brother
this [ __ ] music - man Oh God
uh-oh
sad s that is not yes run run oh oh and
that's the end of pants I think I did
pretty amazing I was actually close I
wasn't paying attention
Drake sword o P sword and that's the end
of that I'm gonna get those doggies ah I
don't know what to do right away you
just run Stace
oh god that that [ __ ] attack is not
even funny
really okay dodge dodge dodge dodge
dodge it nice dodge bro the intro is so
difficult
hahaha I'm pretty sure that's illegal
okay let's let's plan this [ __ ] I'm
gonna try to throw a bomb at them take
it I was stupid
peace oh I killed your doggies now what
you gonna do about that oh that you
could do that time okay well that's cool
nice move piers great job you're
officially a [ __ ]
can I attack him from here well he can
attack me that's her [ __ ] shirt
Bravo pets Brava pants here we go again
let's not die the first thing we [ __ ]
do move your dog sir oh god he did a
movies dog if only he would move his
dogs I walk this bridge so many times
yeah yeah that first attack man
it's easy it's easy just in void yeah
that a tank that's the attack that he
wanted to move or that one for that
[ __ ] matter but what do I care
that's crystal is wearing a skirt
I hate these dogs now yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah take all my help because I didn't
want it anyway
look at this move that pills is about to
perform he says hello
and he says goodbye nice timing
yeah I'm so bad at it Barry that's yeah
hello Harry mother kiss that's that's my
first fairy holy [ __ ] 11 hours into the
game I hate this boss I bet he's a [ __ ]
in real life - absolutely helmet left
forever and I jab na fiscal but oriented
I'd head right yurina Tim it's Tim
meeting table 52 holdren first a jab la
Fitte technique you can and then okay
you can stop god damn you're tall wait
for it wait for it wait for it ah ah ah
a father-to-son tosser
oh ho it's a party I am getting crazy at
this [ __ ] first part man it's not
even [ __ ] funny that's how your time
of attack in the ass okay now your ass
is mine sir your ass is gonna get handed
- mwah
nice move kids oh God
whoo he scares me so much ah ah run pill
train me pal you be vigilant be
beautiful be all these things that
you're not oh god it's like the worst
move ever
oh I'm so lucky what happened when I add
God what are you knowing that's okay I
wasn't doing anything important that guy
just said on my playstation yeah that's
what am i doing here
well I'm never gonna beat him now
absolutely nothing now this [ __ ] is
going down I don't give a [ __ ]
bring it on [ __ ] that's our door in the
port-a-potty - [ __ ] - [ __ ]
don't panic keep your cool how about you
actually dodge some [ __ ] attacks you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't know
what it's like
don't judge me with those eyes
nice throw bro Oh God
oh god I'm dead I don't even know where
he is like it's not even fair oh there
he is
I'm so scared I'm so scared
shut up music nice I hope that was worth
all your health kids hope that was where
folio helps - I got it I'm [ __ ] my
pants here man
well nice attack oh nice attack that
[ __ ] all gone own dead hold on he missed
oh god oh god oh god oh god that is so
much damage but now I'm the other night
what huh oh oh my [ __ ] dick oh my
[ __ ] on Oh hm
hell yeah we did it god damn my hands
are [ __ ] shaking man III don't know
what to say bruh is like the feeling you
get after trying and feeling like this
shit's [ __ ] impossible for two hours
and then all the sudden you get this
weird [ __ ] power fluke I don't know
where and then you kill him that feeling
is this son [ __ ] describable man I
don't know what to do with all these
feelings
alright I'm gonna end this episode here
hope you're watching leave a like if you
did I appreciate all the support in this
series I like I said it's really fun I
feel like you boys are with me on this
hits the sky come to earth today and
I'll see you breasts in the next one
stay awesome love you I do something
look at my tongue oh you like that don't
you it's my t-shirt went to oh I look
like a final fantasy character nice I
always wanted to have a black afro